in terms of change you like it did
change your life physically did it yes
it did I know what you mean yeah yeah
okay right so look basically I have
always had a complex with the way I walk
and I've always been told very every you
know point in my life that I've I'm not
going to be told I've got a bad walk but
someone's always commented on my walk
it's always been a bit like all right so
we might go but yeah so I remember a
mate of mine at school said because I've
quite I'm not this won't happen but I
love quite pronounced calf muscles I
always thought that hereditary thing but
I remember my mate once we were talking
about it we didn't just sit rule and
talk about that
we have great and I said he said you
know why upper caste I said no I think
it's cuz my dad does it's hereditary he
said no no it's cuz you walk in there
tiptoes so I was like it's not a weird
thing whatever anyway a couple of jobs
have done the first day that we did the
fall and I had the walk and the director
or the producer writer Alan Kubek came
up and said it's a character thing or I
could be trying to cover my way out of
it and I thought no I just told you that
is how I walk so we started working
things he started talking about why
don't you take maybe take longer strides
so and then with my wife and I would
walk around where we live in in London
and because I'm bear cuz I'm on my
tiptoes I'm quite hi I'm Craig pine see
my wife who said why don't you try the
leaning back right I'll say son
literally walk and we go out for walks
and idolic tree so that I'll show you
mate this is my old walk right that is
the old walk I'm so excited
don't get that excited this is my I'm so
I just saying no oh there's my old book
okay this is my this is what we tried
right with my wife remember those
commercials were mister saw
and then this is what oh just what we
settled on and I'll tell you how we got
there is it so [__] okay I knew what
you'll see anyone
so I got there was I have to dance in
just a little bit dancing a 52-degree
and that was I can't dance at all so I
mean I they asked me could I dance and I
was like yeah done so I had dance
lessons and it was like Foxtrot those
rights are classic and the the dance
teacher I was really struggling with it
and the dance teacher said you know what
you need to do just think about it as
walking as well literally the first
thing you learn to do in life that's
funny great he said you know just
thinking walk heel heel to toe heel to
toe I was like I like more - I just
apply that every day and I'm walking are
thing is I haven't seen you do many sex
scenes and I have looked young woman
named Kate is beautiful and I am getting
a divorce